[Musique]
nous pouvons commencer par un petit tour
de table sur ce qui a été dit par le
premier ministre peut-être que monsieur
andré laignel où monsieur boulard allez
monsieur voulait recommencer
prenez le micro oui vous avez entendu
écouté le premier ministre il ya eu on
va vous entendre à ouvrir micro dans un
instant il n'y a pas eu d'annoncé
fracassante de la part du premier
ministre parce qu'il ya de bourg et de
la finance qui arrive bientôt mais on a
entendu quand même quelques petites
briques danon ce qu'est ce que vous en
pensez vous attendez je crois qu'il a
été dit les choses extrêmement
importantes
tout à l'heure il conforme à ce qui
avait été dit lors de la rencontre entre
le président actuel et la mfm rappeler
deux trois choses sur la sphère de la
taxe d'habitation
trois mots ont été prononcés
dégrèvements et non pas compensation ce
n'est pas rien
chirac actuellement les 4 milliards de
ce genre des dégrèvements et aucune
majorité ne s'est permis de remettre en
cause ce dégrèvement préservation du
pouvoir de taux avec un joie 2017 pour
le taux est pas vraiment une dernière
discussion sur l'enrichissement des
bases je trouve qu'il ya sur ce premier
sujet confirme après on peut penser ce
qu'on veut de lévitation
mais au moins sur les conditions dans
lesquelles s'est mis en oeuvre c'est
conforme à ce qui a été déclaré
y'a quoi il faut que c'est plutôt
populaire dans ma ville donc je vous
conseille aux élus des prudents
lorsqu'ils font des déclarations sur la
taxe d'habitation
entre nous on va prendre les choses dans
l'ordre la tête d'impression dont
parlait entre les élus passent leur
temps à donner leur point de vue
peut-être de temps en temps tenir compte
du point de vue de ce combat on ferme
en tout cas taxe d'habitation s'est
clarifiée au moins sur la méthode
deuxième chose on a vécu depuis quatre
ans des baisses de dotations
on nous annonce ça me paraît quand même
un scénario nouveau 2018
pas de baisses de dotations dès lors que
vous accepterez de discuter
d'une réduction de dépenses de
fonctionnement dans le cadre d'une
contractualisation est là aussi ceux qui
critiquent etc ont soutenu trouvé de
majorité précédent qui a l'air en
matière de baisses de dotations je
trouve que pour au moins accepter la
discussion sur blanc que passer de ces
scénarios la table ronde il va bien
enfin non salées moi j'en ai assez des
critiques fausses surtout de la part de
ce qu'ont soutenu une majorité qui
baissaient les dotations peut-être quand
même pas perdre la mémoire
je constate que sur ce point il ya une
évolution
alors on peut être pour ou contre moi je
préfère un contrat de baise des
fonctionnements plutôt qu'à une annonce
en 2018 à nouveau d'une baisse de
dotation site où je trouve que chercher
deux points
s'il ya plutôt une évolution
intéressante autant de carole quelqu'un
est ce que vous partagez la vie de
monsieur boulin est ce que tout va bien
et que en tout cas ça va moins mal
je ne suis pas certaine d'être dans
cette maman dans cet esprit où tout va
bien il me semble que les annonces quand
même de moins de 13 milliards de baisse
alors moi j'étais membre du précédent
gouvernement donc bien sûr j'assume la
baisse des 10 milliards sous le
précédent quinquennat
je me permets de rappeler que ça avait
été indiqué comme un effort des
collectivités locales qui devait être
limité dans le temps là on nous annonce
au début j'étais 10 milliards on nous
annonce 13 milliards on apprend deux
jours après la conférence des
territoires qui à une baisse de 300
millions d'euros
donc moi je n'ai pas le même optimisme
voilà que mon prédécesseur sur ce sur ce
sujet là il faut être quand même
conscient que d'arrivées de nouveau à
une baisse de 13 milliards pour
l'ensemble des collectivités locales va
mettre en grande difficulté l'action des
collectivités locales alors moi je fais
partie des élus je tiens à le dire à
monsieur le maire d'humains qui écoutent
ce que disent les citoyennes leur bien
entendu qu'on leur dit vous allez plus
payer d'impôts ils sont ravis que ce
soit la taxe d'habitation ou n'importe
quel être impôts en revanche ils sont
aussi très exigeant sur les services à
la population qu'ils sont amenés et je
pense que aussi bien sur le bloc
communal que sur le blog départementales
ou bloc régional
il y a des missions
qui sont fortement attendues en tant que
présidente de région on peut parler
quand même de tout ce qui concerne
l'investissement ferroviaire où la sncf
se désengage de plus en plus et oussalah
région qui doit financer des travaux
alors que ce ne sont pas ses compétences
donc non je ne suis pas béate
d'admiration
je suis bien sûr d'aller au narnia mais
un partenariat très vigilants voilà est
très exigeant et vous avez entendu ce
qu'a dit le premier ministre a peut-être
monsieur légal va prendre la parole dans
un instant je salue d'ailleurs également
la présence de françois baroin président
de l'amf qui s'exprimera tout à l'heure
monsieur laignel le pré ministre a
rappelé pas de baisse en 2018 du
concours financier de concours
financiers ou vous pour les finances
dans le territoire il l'a rappelé deux
fois il n'y aura pas de baisse elle
cotait j'attends la présentation du
projet de loi de finances mais comme ça
a été annoncé je suppose que ça sera en
cohérence en même temps si on ne baisse
pas en 2018 mais qu'on nous dit qu'on
doit baisser nos moyens de 13 milliards
sur le quinquennat ça veut dire qu'on
étalera sur quatre ans au lieu d'étaler
sur cinq ans ce qui ne me rassure pas
franchement en somme il vous demande de
faire un effort sur le quinquennat si on
a bien compris ce qu'il disait tout à
l'heure
est-ce que vous avez d'ailleurs vous
avez tout compris de ce qu'il est j'ai
compris les titres mais je n'ai pas les
développements donc vous comprendrez
j'attende d'avoir le mode d'emploi pour
savoir ce qu'il ya derrière le titre
mais si vraiment il faut baisser les
dépenses des collectivités territoriales
de 13 milliards sur le quinquennat
je considère que c'est inatteignable et
irresponsable
tout simplement parce que nous ne sommes
pas au début du processus
ça fait dix ans qu'on serre les boulons
ça fait dix ans qu'on a une politique
d'économies dans nos collectivités
territoriales et malheureusement ça a
des répercussions sur les trois
dernières années pour le bloc communal
c'est moins 25% d'investissements sur
les 5 dernières années pour le bloc
communal
c'est moins 35 % 35 % d'autofinancement
nette alors vous savez
c'est comme dans les régimes les
premiers kilos c'est les plus faciles à
perdre
mais si vous prolonger trop longtemps le
régime
ça peut être la nagra ici et beaucoup de
nos collectivités n'en sont pas loin
vous dites donc quelque part qu'il ya
danger
il y as danger est en tout cas je
considère que moins 13 milliards de
dépenses ce n'est pas raisonnable
d'abord c'est passé de 10 à 13 milliards
en 72 heures sont on ait la moindre
explication
j'ai d'ailleurs personnellement poser la
question premier ministre il ne m'a
jamais répondu sur ce sujet je veux dire
savait alors maintenant on nous dit mais
vous allez voir c'est moins douloureux
que ça en a l'air
mais ça me rappelle un peu ces
commerçants qui augmentent les prix la
veille des soldes pour expliquer
qu'après ils font un bon rabais
là on nous a taxés de 10 à 13 milliards
d'un seul coup et maintenant vous dites
mais ce sera peut-être un peu moins
là j'attends quand même d'avoir la
facture finale monsieur rénald si vous
l'étiez 1.2 micro également honte
indignes et de nous dire que je ne
pouvais plus faire d'économie qu'on
était à la hausse si on peut dire en
tout cas que j'avais donges et vous
partagez vous partager ce constat il
peut pas y avoir aujourd'hui une baisse
de 13 milliards en quatre ans sans qu'il
y ait des conséquences sur la qualité
des services publics sur le territoire
alors on peut dire les choses et le
résumé de cette façon là je crois que
tout ceci doit être donc regarder avec
beaucoup de prudence si on ne peut pas
en tout cas à adhérer à l'objectif de
cette baisse supplémentaire alors tout à
leurs collègues boulard et à me disais
mais on avait accepté d'ailleurs avait
beaucoup de difficultés malgré tout si
se souvient de nos débats la baisse
brutale de 10 5 milliards d'euros mais
la situation était totalement différente
à l'époque le déficit de l'état s'était
5,1 pour cent
il y avait des difficultés
éventuellement à trouver du crédit
international pour payer la dette donc
pour financer la dette donc on est dans
une situation qui nécessitait des
actions fortes où elle a regretté
mais en tout cas c'était un climat très
particulier nous sommes aujourd'hui à 3%
sommes dans un climat donc totalement
différent et donc ça s'inscrit pas du
tout dans le même esprit ensuite dire
que la méthode par exemple de
contractualisation est une méthode utile
et qu'on est prêt à regarder comment les
choses se passent l'idée de dire ont
contractualisé avec les 350 plus gros on
verra comment ils ont défini exactement
pour 70 % de la dépense pourquoi pas ça
peut être pourquoi vous dites pourquoi
non mais c'est mieux qu'un rabot
généralisé
ça c'est tout à fait indiscutable la
méthode a du bon celle mais il ya
toujours des choses qui sont dans ce qui
est proposé qui peuvent être bons mais
ce qui est pas aussi l'objectif de base
c'est à dire que si on n'allait pas à 13
milliards et finalement de belles des
services publics faut dire les choses
comme ça de baisse de l'investissement
public
eh bien on n'aurait pas se poser la
question de la méthode monsieur moi j'ai
parlé que développe le coup là je vais
aller que deux méthodes je préfère la
méthode de proposer à ce qu'on a vécu
si on est d'accord est ce qu'on a vécu
qu'on la suive très bien moi j'ai des
convaincus je trouve pas bien du rêve
d'entendre des discours successifs
selon koné de la majorité ou pas il faut
savoir assumer des bêtises c'était une
béquille bon là on nous propose une
méthode qui était différent et du ray à
la mer c'est la proposition jeunes et
deuxièmement je constate que l'état nous
propose de faire quelques économies
il sort des quatre jours en matière
scolaire qui nous pauvres colère c'est
pas rien quand même
moi j'ai des millions et des millions
d'euros nets
enfin que j'ai une chance d'économies en
2010 lui faut quand même qu'on voit que
nous n'avons aujourd'hui un gouvernement
qui arrêtent qualifié d' arrêter
d'imposer des dépenses moi je prenais
une liste de dépenses précédente celle
là en est une histoire je trouve qu'il
ya là une perspective d'économie alors
on utilise on utilise ma on aime ou on
aime pas je sais ma collectivité
on a commencé à regarder
contractuellement quelles sont les
économies que l'on pouvait faire qui
sont les en plus des cuivres légitime
dès lors que l'état nous a allégé d'un
centre de débats entre la méthode et le
cette différence on arrête un état qui
décident de dépenses qui sont à notre
cause qu'on a rien vécu en matière
scolaire dans des proportions
considérables chez vrai qu'on n'oublie
pas ce qu'on a vécu est la petite
différence qu'on nous propose c'est tout
cela m'étonne vous imaginez que des
réactions d'avoir un peu de miel carole
delga juste après non mais moi je suis
d'autant plus à l'aise que j'ai combattu
les baisses de dotations sous le
quinquennat précédent
tout le monde n'était moins donc le
procès vis-à-vis de ceux qui
éventuellement des fondé notre politique
qui pouvait avoir ses justifications
même si je la partageais pas ne me
concerne pas je veux le dire très
clairement et surtout la situation a
évolué aujourd'hui les collectivités
territoriales ont fait l'effort alors
que l'état ne l'a pas fait je rappelle
que les collectivités territoriales en
2016 c'est le rapport de l'observatoire
que j'ai présentée il ya une quinzaine
de jours devant le comité des finances
locales en 2016
les collectivités territoriales ont
dégagé 4,2 milliards de moyens de
financement
pendant le même temps l'état a accru son
déficit accru son déficit de 2,1
milliards
et si globalement la france a vu son
déficit baisser c'est uniquement parce
que les collectivités territoriales
auront fait l'effort alors que ça soit à
nouveau vers l con ce tourne et qu'on
leur dise serrez vous la ceinture c'est
pas les collectivités qui serre la
ceinture ce sont les citoyens
c'est une démarche qui n'est pas
acceptable
telle qu'elle est proposée aujourd'hui
je vais prendre un seul exemple d'abord
raisonner sur les dépenses est pour moi
une absurdité
j'ouvre au 1er janvier dans ma ville des
structures pour la petite enfance
ça coûte très cher la petite enfance
mais évidemment on ne raisonne pas
forcément uniquement en terme comptable
quand on décide qu'on aide les familles
qu'on ait de la petite enfance
est-ce que je vais être un mauvais mère
parce que je vais accroître ma dépenses
publiques de manière considérable au
bénéfice de nos concurrents selon lequel
sont ici sont les retours que vous avez
et justement les sacrifices que vous
allez devoir faire mais je n'en ferai
pas il faudra utiliser la contrainte si
on veut me faire faire des sacrifices
car je n'accepte pas de baisser le
service public dans ma communauté et
donc il n'y aura pas d'augmentation
d'impôts par exemple ça fait 14 ans que
je n'ai pas augmenter les taux
d'imposition de ma ville que j'ai essayé
de serrer tout ce qui pouvait être s'est
réveillé un moment où il n'y a plus de
marge et les seuls marchés soit baissée
l'investissement donc l'autofinancement
j'ai rappelé que ça avait baissé de plus
de 35 % pour le bloc communal ce qui est
considérable et ce qui fait que
évidemment maintenant nous n'agissons
plus que sur les 65 % qui restent et que
nous avons d'autre part - 25 % en trois
ans d'investissements publics et souvent
ce ne sont pas des investissements
obligatoirement nouveau c'est de
l'entretien et on sait bien que si on
décale de l'entretien ça coûtera encore
beaucoup plus cher à la collectivité
donc c'est une politique j'allais dire
c'est le père ubu c'est le père ubu
carole delga présidente de la région
occitanie justement sur ce vaste
territoire comment est ce que vous
faites alors tout d'abord je voudrais
quand même rappeler que à avant de
parler de cosmétiques il faut quand même
parler du fond donc avant la méthode ont
bien sûr de la concertation personne
n'est contre la concertation mais il
faut savoir une baisse de 13 milliards
est elle tenable et on ne peut pas être
juste vendre sur la réforme des rythmes
scolaires sur une vision purement
comptable
je pense quand même que le service
public de l'éducation en premier doit
être sur des valeurs sûres des
conditions d'égalité des chances
avant de parler quand même d'addition
alors ensuite sur le fait que le
gouvernement ne
ferait plus de transferts de compétences
sans compensation financière je suis
très étonné vous indiquez monsieur
goulard quand même parce que pour le
réseau ferroviaire
quand on indique que les régions vont
devoir financer des réfections de rails
alors que c'est d'incompétence que la
sncf comme en matière agricole et vous
le savez nous avons un fort déficit sur
les aides aux agriculteurs et que l'état
ne va pas tenir ses engagements et m'a
demandé aux régions de les compenser
sans qu'il y ait de transfert également
sur les aides économiques
nous avions obtenu un engagement de
l'état s'était donc l'année dernière sur
le fait qu'une part de la fraction de la
tva sans augmentation de la tva à peu
près un demi point soit transféré pour
compenser donc la dgf mais également la
dotation qui avaient été obtenus sous le
gouvernement valse de 450 millions pour
les aides aux entreprises qui sont
absolument indispensables pour pouvoir
aider nos entreprises à s'adapter aux
nouvelles mutations qui sont que ce soit
dans le cadre des énergies renouvelables
les mots de mutations technologiques
donc soyons quand même lucides bien
entendu qu'une concertation est une
bonne chose
- d'indiquer quand treize milieu que 13
milliards sur quatre ans on va arriver à
les faire juste dans la douceur ce n'est
pas vrai il va y avoir des situations
très délicates et en particulier au
niveau des départements ou au niveau des
petites communes il n'y a plus de marge
j'ai été maire je connais bien ce que
c'est que la gestion municipale
je connais j'étais quand j'étais député
à la commission des finances
je connais aussi la tension extrême que
vivent les conseil départemental avec
l'explosion des dépenses sociales et les
régions nous avons des défis à mener
pour la région occitanie ya aussi la lgv
qui est absolument indispensable
nous avons tous le développement des
entreprises et des petites entreprises
en particulier
donc soyons réalistes c'est 13 milliards
vont mettre à genoux certaines de nos
collectivités locales il va y avoir
moins de services à la population
- de service également et
d'accompagnement aux entreprises qu'on
doit accompagner et cela va être dans la
difficulté
je me permet quand même de rappeler que
70%
de l'investissement public est assuré
par les collectivités locales et dans ma
région
dès que j'ai été élu j'ai mis en place
un plan marshall nous avons augmenté
l'investissement de 20 % chaque année
c'est un milliard d'euros qui est
investit chaque année et nous faisons en
sorte que la commande publique régionale
elles puissent bénéficier par les
entreprises locales aux habitants de
notre région
c'est cela être responsable et c'est
cela aussi mener une gestion pour
l'avenir de la population de nos
territoires
juste une question m d'ehlg un juge pour
terminer sur ce point parce que le
constat que vous faites est très amer
mais qu'est ce que vous demandez en fait
aujourd'hui plus d'autonomie vous
demander de stopper dans le choix de la
clarté
voilà nous expliquer qu'on va diminuer
de 13 milliards les dotations aux
collectivités locales sans baisser les
dotations sans slip
bon il faut quand même se parler de
façon si une décision du gouvernement
il en a toute la légitimité mais connaît
une clarté de la relation avec les
collectivités locales
on nous a réunis en grande pompe au
sénat deux jours après un signe un
décret en catimini ce n'est pas
respectueux je manque de la clarté je
demande aussi la promesse les que les
promesses des présidents gouvernement
elles soient tenus pour les régions nous
avons je veux dire 8 % d'autonomie
fiscale 8% +6 8 % d'autonomie fiscale
je n'ai pas 1 92% des dotations ce qui
avait été décidé avec le précédent
gouvernement
c'est que nous ayons une fraction de la
tva ce qui leur permet d'avoir une
refiscalisation des recettes et l'art
maintenant on nous indique que la
refiscalisation sera moindre et que la
compensation du transfert de la
compétence économie n'y serait plus je
demande de la clarté du réalisme je
demande également qu'on soit conscient
de toutes les actions que mènent les
collectivités locales pour la croissance
de la france et je pense également qu on
doit se rappeler que l'investissement
public la dépense publique n'est pas
forcément mauvaise on s'est très bien
pendant matière de transport toute
période de croissance économique tous
les économistes vous le dit
toute période de croissance économique
allait précéder d'un investissement fort
dans les transports et c'est pourquoi
nous devons nous battre pour avoir aidé
lgv et des transports du quotidien et de
quoi ministre l'a dit il y aura dans le
projet de loi de finances le maintien
des investissements sur le territoire on
verra évidemment d'ici une dizaine de
jours ce qui l'autre à claude raynal
peut-être sur tout ce qui vient d'être
dit et pour approfondir un peu les
différents sujets notamment sur les
compétences
oui moi je crois que le propos de carole
delga est important la question de la
clarté
souvent le mot de confiance il dit mais
derrière la confiance et à la clarté
quel est l'objectif finalement que l'on
se donne collectivement et quelle est la
part que chacun d'eux pendant sept dans
cet effort
le premier point cela a été rappelé par
andré laignel très justement c'est que
dans la période récente ce sont les
collectivités locales qui ont fait
l'essentiel de l'effort voilà donc il
faut que cette réalité soit prise en
compte aujourd'hui est donc le débat sur
les 13 milliards c'est un débat qu'on
doit avoir de toutes façons pour que
personne autour de la table mais comment
dire les inconscients sur le fait que
collectivement nous devons trouver une
solution à notre pays n'y a pas de doute
là dessus que les collectivités locales
font partie du paysage que la question
de savoir s'il faut pour plus
d'investissements sur des politiques
d'état ou des politiques locales
c'est évident également qu'il doit y
avoir là dessus une discussion et une
accroche parce qu'il n'est pas trop ça
mais par contre mais par contre dire
d'entrée ses 10 avec un pourcentage
d'ailleurs qu'il faut puisque c'est
celui d impulser pas se lier
collectivités territoriales paso c'est
trois de plus sans qu'on sache pourquoi
sauf que deux jours avant il y avait la
baisse de 3 milliards liés à l'impôt sur
la fortune on est obligé quelque part de
se dire il ya des liens entre les choses
on est obligé voilà et donc il faut de
la clarté et dans ce chiffre de 13
milliards il n'est pas intangible il
doit être sur la table et doit être
discuté de manière à voir l'effort réel
que doivent faire les collectivités
locales et à quel rythme ça peut se
faire
ce premier débat est ans et ensuite on
peut rentrer sur les discussions
techniques il ya des éléments que jean
claude boulard a rappelé ont très bien
il y en a d'autres
il y en a bien d'autres ea le point de
démarrage c'est un point important
important qui a été souligné total
mais ça va être un sujet le deuxième
sujet qui est intéressant c'est
effectivement de dire on va prendre en
compte la croissance naturelle des
dépenses
c'est une évidence il faut que ça soit
pris en compte et donc faisons le est ce
que ce sera une pente
hors inflation avec inflation 1,2 pour
cent 1 % 1,1 l'air de rien 0 1 sur la
durée ça fait mal donc regardons le avec
avec précision s'est ouvert on le
regarde mais maintenant il faut avancer
il faut qu'on arrive
effectivement un résultat qui nous
convient de tous enfin on a des
territoires qui se développe à des
rythmes différents
tout à l'heure andré a dit si je suis
obligé d'ouvrir une école une crèche etc
c'est pas vrai sur tous les territoires
donc il faut tenir compte aussi d'un
pouvoir de qui tiennent compte de la
nécessité d'augmenter la dépense par
rapport à certaines progression de
population
tous ces sujets évidemment ne sont pas
aujourd'hui d'un traité et donc doit
être sur la table pour nous faire
progresser collectivement la clarté
carole delga position c'est très
important la confiance c'est un état
d'esprit
la clarté c'est des choses très précises
et sur un point très précis qui était
dans le dans le manifeste que vous avez
tous signé au mois de mars il y avait le
voeu d'une loi de financement des
collectivités
est-ce que ce voeu pieux aujourd'hui nom
alors je crois qu on peut en parler avec
avec andré aa2 à a2 voix il y avait
l'idée d'un projet de loi de financement
des collectivités locales jeunesse et je
laisserais andré faire une une nuance
qui me paraît extrêmement importante car
ce que nous souhaitons d'un point de vue
législatif est dans une période le
président goodluck a évoqué ce matin où
il ya une séparation des pouvoirs entre
les élus locaux et le parlement il est
très important il est très important que
l'on sorte d' un dévot parlementaire où
les élus locaux avaient leur part de
responsabilité comme s'il était
parlementaire d'avoir des amendements de
milieu de nuit
au mois de décembre pour modifier toutes
ont modifié à la marge par et il m'est
souvent de manière extrêmement forte les
textes pour faire bénéficier telle ou
telle collectivité de tel ou tel
avantage ça il faut en sortir
et si on peut passer par un projet de
loi de finances spécifique pour les
collectivités locales dans lequel tous
ces éléments qui concerne les collecter
territoriale soit dans ce projet de loi
ce sera quelque chose d'important et je
crois que ça il faut être pour par
contre loi de financement je laisse
andrée petelle rendirent loi de
financement entre les nièces que cette
imaginables faisable alors il faut faire
la différence
pardon on va rentrer un peu dans le
détail entre loi de finances et lois de
financement
la loi de financement serait
parallèle avec celles qui existent pour
la sécurité sociale je rappelle qu'elle
est contraignante
ce qui n'est pas acceptable pour la mf
et je pense pour l'ensemble des
collectivités territoriales alors que la
loi de finances
c'est le recueil de l'ensemble des
articles de la loi de finances qui
impactent directement ou indirectement
les collectivités territoriales et qui
permettent ainsi d'avoir un débat global
sur le sort pour faire nos collectivités
territoriales je vais recevoir mardi les
membres du gouvernement plus que le cfl
a le privilège d'entendre la loi de
finances la veille du conseil des
ministres pour la partie qui concerne
les collectivités locales
mais comme d'habitude on va nous donner
les grandes lignes mais on va pas
forcément nous donner le détail des
articles qui nous intacte et nous
ressortons à chaque fois relativement
insatisfaits parce qu'on a qu'une toute
petite partie de la réalité qui
s'imposera à nos collectivités
donc oui à une loi de finances qui
laisse la liberté aux collectivités
territoriales mais qui permet la
transparence que nous appelons tous de
nos voeux j'ajoute qu'on pourrait en
profiter aussi pour mettre en place
juridiquement ce que j'appelle l'article
40 vous savez que dans la constitution
il est un article 40 qui prévoit que
aucune dépense ne peut être engagée s'il
n'y a pas les recettes correspondantes
émergents souhaitent nous souhaitons
collectivement que l'article 40 soit
transposée aux collectivités locales ce
qui éviterait les dérives que nous
connaissons je vous indique simplement
que la moyenne des cinq dernières années
en dépenses nouvelles qui nous ont été
imposées c'est un milliard par an 1
milliard par an qui est venu s'ajouter
bien entendu aux baisses de moyens que
nous avons eues à amortir donc c'est
considérable et j'ai donc l'intention de
mettre le cfl le comité des finances
locales au travail je l'indiqueraient
mardi sur la mise en oeuvre d'une loi de
finances et d'un article 40 au bénéfice
des collectivités territoriales ça fera
partie du programme de travail que je
soumettrai aux cfl mardi
jean claude boulard notre résumé tout
cela sinon j'avais l'impression que on
préférait l'idée d'arrêter la baisse des
dotations
je prends acte moi je préfère chez
requins ne préfère pas et on se munit de
ce qu'ils ont fait je trouve que c'est
une évolution pendant cinq ans après
comment ça va se faire c'est autre chose
c'est une évolution intéressante
j'aurais aimé l'entendre je n'ai pas
entendu c'est pour ça que je lui dis
n'oubliez pas ce qu'on avait
deuxièmement je trouve que c'est bien un
gouvernement qui annonce qu'il ne fera
plus de dépenses à charge des
collectivités locales je vous signale
qu'on se prend en ce moment le transfert
du pacs du parc.ce des greffes vers nous
c'est très coûteux
c'est la majorité précédents jeux tout
arrêter ce système entre les rythmes
scolaires
nous avons la possibilité de faire une
économie goûter aux personnes comme le
parti c'est une réalité
je trouve que c'est une évolution
extrêmement intéressante
après il faudra être vigilant et tu nous
tiens un deuxième changement qui peut
nous aider à faire des économies
troisième élément sur les collectivités
locales leurs situations financières
faites gaffe parce que on est tous un
peu excédentaires donc fait un peu
attention les tailles déficitaire notre
drame trois exclusions c'est qu'on est
tous excédentaire c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut pas et 2e en chantant
heureusement quelques maires ruraux qui
disent je le dis pas mais les
péréquations ont largement plus que
largement atténué les baisses de
dotations
il ya aussi un moment de vérité bon
j'arrête des sénateurs dont trois jours
je préfère ma ville mais j'ai entendu
pour tout le débat et vert ruraux que
l'honnêteté de me dire honnêtement en
matière de notation
ça s'est plutôt pas trop mal passé ça
n'a pas été le cas du ville voilà aussi
qu'on arrête d'opposer un peu trop les
des territoires voilà des éléments à
mettre un but sur la table et une
volonté de et dernier rang de vérité et
dernière chose un débat sur les centres
de loisirs par exemple ou si aujourd'hui
on allège un peu les normes
si au lieu d'avoir si personne ne sait
pas quelles sont les règles aujourd'hui
on dit y a
un encadrant deux mois on a pout pour un
produit qui est plutôt bien
il ya aussi probablement à discuter avec
l'état c'est une réalité dans le débat
des nantes dans le débat des
encadrements mes fesses et on peut
continuer simplement on peut continuer
moi je préfère donner alderson
d'évolution de méthodes de partir à
nouveau de vives critiques
je crois que c'est pas mal de dire on va
bien voir il ya quelques pistes
d'évolution qui sont intéressants qui ne
sont pas des garanties mais qu'il est
utile de tester voilà c'est tout je vais
parler mais andré laignel répond à
monsieur couleurs et a passé sa taxe
d'habitation aux deux motions j'aime
beaucoup jean claude et il le sait mais
comme il est habile il nous parle de la
méthode pour éviter de parler du fond la
méthode si c'est une méthode de dialogue
personne ne peut être contre mais si le
dialogue a pour objectif de nous faire
avaler 13 milliards de baisse de nos
voyants alors excusez moi de vous dire
que la méthode n'a strictement aucune
importance
et donc ce qui est en débat ce sont les
13 milliards ce qui est en débat c'est
le recul de l'autonomie fiscale des
collectivités avec la suppression de la
taxe d'habitation
parce qu'on nous dit moi j'ai noté très
exactement ce qu'a dit sur le sujet le
premier ministre il a dit elle est
injuste oui bien juste oui je confirme
mais on nous a déjà fait le même coup
avec la taxe professionnelle elle était
abc et je disais oui sauf qu'on l'a
remplacé par plus imbécile encore car on
n'est toujours pas sorti de l'ajustement
des compensations pour celles qui ne
sont pas gelés et on est dans la panade
absolue en ce qui concerne par exemple
la cvae bien donc oui bien sûr c'est
injuste mais ya des moyens de la rendre
juste sans la supprimer
c'est par exemple de réviser et de
pistes de les bains réfection de réviser
les bases locatives
parce que ce qui rend particulièrement
injuste aujourd'hui ce sont les bases et
si on décide de ne pas toucher aux bases
alors ça ne concernera plus que 20% de
ceux qui payent la taxe d'habitation que
les basques continue à être injuste mais
ça concernera aussi tous
eux qui ont la taxe foncière tous ceux
qui ont la taxe d'enlèvement des ordures
ménagères
donc ça continuera à être injuste sur
des pans considérable et pour certains
les 20% n'est ce pas qui sont forcément
des ultra riches c'est bien connu ça
continuera à peser
donc c'est pas la bonne méthode ça n'est
pas acceptable
et quant à dire que parce que c'est un
dégrèvement ce serait gravée dans le
marbre
c'est une plaisanterie en 2000 lorsque
la taxe d'habitation a été supprimée
pour les régions c'était un dégrèvement
tout le mandat dure bravo en 2001 2000
2001 la loi de finances les a
transformés en exonération il ne reste
quasiment plus rien aujourd'hui donc
nous avons été instruit par l'exemple et
nous ne sommes pas obligés d'être des
croyants sans être sûr que la fois
suffisent à ouvrir nos esprits et
surtout nos collectivités de goût
demande au gouvernement quelque part de
prendre sur temps sur cette question
d'avoir un retour d'expérience peut-être
lors du cnt le conseil national des
territoires éventuellement bien entendu
mais plutôt que de dire on supprime dès
2018 la taxe d'habitation puisqu'on dit
qu'il faut une réforme de la fiscalité
est bien travail ont immédiatement pour
la mettre en oeuvre
en 2019 et ayant un ans de moratoire qui
nous permettra de travailler
intelligemment
je rappelle d'ailleurs que le comité des
finances locales n'a pas attendu pour
réfléchir sur le problème de la
fiscalité
puisque il y avait une lettre de mission
de jean marc ayrault au cfl en ce qui me
concerne au président du cfl que j'ai
fait travailler le cfl pendant 18 mois
que nous avons rendu une copie unanime
au cfl sur les grandes orientations de
ce que devrait être une réforme fiscale
donc nous avons le matériau de base on
est parfaitement capable de se remettre
au travail immédiatement et de faire des
propositions au gouvernement donc nous
sommes dans une démarche de propositions
mais si on nous dit ah ben non on vous
supprime d'abord la taxe d'habitation en
vous suppriment des libertés locales et
après on discute alors ça n'est pas
acceptable car le père gaza faisait
partie un petit peu des questions
d'autonomie dont vous parliez tout à
l'heure mais vous pour parler quelques
sur quelques moues notamment sur la taxe
d'habitation suez si vous le voulez bien
mais déjà il a été dit que les
collectivités locales sont excédentaires
il faut rappeler que les budgets des
collectivités locales ils doivent être
quand même voter un équilibre et que on
a cette obligation la queue n'a pas
l'état de plus rappelé que quand on voit
les analyse plus détaillée de la
situation financière des collectivités
locales
c'est quand même on voit un
autofinancement qui est en train de se
dégrader et la reprise qui avait eu lieu
l'année dernière sur l'investissement
public risquent fortement d'être rodé
rien qu'avec le signal de la suppression
un peu qui s'est fait en catimini des
300 millions d'euros qui a eu lieu alors
sur l'autonomie fiscale doit rappeler
quand même que c'est un principe
constitutionnel nous devons normalement
les collectivités locales de par le
principe de libre administration pouvoir
fixer nos recettes pour les régions ce
n'est plus le cas puisque ça a été en
fait des différentes étapes de
suppression des fiscale la fiscalité et
on est en moyenne à 8 %
c'est des taxes crise celle vax sur la
carte grise que nous avons ces 8 % de
nos recettes sur lesquelles nous avons
un pouvoir de décision donc ce qui est
arrivé aux régions je voudrais pas que
ça arrive à d'autres structures du bloc
communal ou du bloc départementale parce
que nous avons une vraie problématique
en france c'est que nous pouvons aussi
avoir une autonomie financière qui
pourrait ne pas être une autonomie
fiscale parce que si nous avons une
garantie des dotations qui est au niveau
constitutionnel comme c'est le cas en
allemagne
à ce moment là nous avons une autonomie
financière parce que chaque année nous
dépendons nous sommes pieds et poings
liés du vote du projet de loi de
finances et là nous ne pouvons pas
continuer à enlever le pouvoir de
décision de la fiscalité si en
contrepartie nous n'avons pas une
garantie constitutionnelle l'année
dernière on nous dit sur le pellec 2018
pour les régions fraction de tva qui
compense la dgf et qui compensent est
également le transfert de la compétence
économie là maintenant
nous parle plus que juste la dgf juste
donné quand même un chiffre entre 2014
et 2017 sur le budget de la région
occitanie qui fait 3 milliards 4 c'est
135 millions d'euros de moins de dgf
et si je cumule c'est 300 millions
d'euros de moins aimé prédécesseur mais
s'est laissé une très bonne situation
financière parce que nous avons voulu
pouvoir être en capacité d'investir et
malgré cela on a fait des efforts on ne
peut pas dire que les collectivités
locales nous sommes pas en
responsabilité les dépenses de
fonctionnement de 2016 et 2017 et ou de
2015 à 2016 ont augmenté de 2 5%
j'augmente mes dépenses de
fonctionnement de 1 5% malgré la fusion
est ce qui crée quand même une certaine
réorganisation et parfois certaines
complications mais on l'a fait et on a
contenu de l'épave fonctionnant pour
pouvoir plus investir parce qu'on a
besoin d'accompagner cette croissance
donc l'autonomie des l'autonomie fiscale
est indispensable en france parce que
nous n'avons pas une autonomie
financière qui est garantie par la
constitution et donc moi je pense que la
réforme la taxe d'habitation
elle est vraiment très important
seulement dangereuse et ce qui a été
cité au niveau de la taxe d'habitation
des régions c'est à dire on est passé
d'un dégrèvement gras une compensation
juste de le vote d'une loi de finances
il n'y a pas une pérennité dans ces
décisions là et c'est ce qui pose
vraiment le problème de fond la taxe
d'habitation sont propres le problème
défend c'est pas juste d'un exonérés
c'est de dire quelles sont les
conditions d'un position par rapport au
foncier par rapport à la valeur foncière
et c'est vrai que c'est sur les bases
que nous devons revoir une réforme avait
été entamée aussi sur la dgf nous savons
très bien qu'au niveau de la dgf
il y avait une question vraiment qui est
d'inéquité qui est très forte parce que
nous devons prendre en compte avant tout
pour la dgf le revenu par habitant des
collectivités locales
9 le vrai indicateur du besoin de
l'intervention de la collectivité locale
de la dépense c'est le revenu par
habitant
quelle que soit la strate parce que
quand mon avant nous avons une
population
qui est assez paupérisée ou un revenu
par habitant faible les collectivités
locales comme l'état d'ailleurs doivent
plus investir c'est vrai pour les écoles
c'est vrai pour les tarifs sociaux pour
les transports en commun c'est vrai pour
le budget de la formation aussi donc la
réforme la taxe d'habitation
elle doit se faire à l'aune d'une
réflexion plus large sur la relation
entre l'imposition du foncier et le
citoyen et les services qui sont on va
avancer une conclusion si vous le voulez
bien ce que dans quelques minutes on va
appeler le président de la fff jean luc
moudenc à venir sur le pupitre ici pour
pour conclure cette matinée tout à
l'heure le premier ministre en a fait
appel à l'esprit d'hubert en quelque
sorte d'esprit du maire c'est le
consensus et dépasser les clivages
politiques
aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'il ya une
forme de colère de la part d' ici de
nombreux élus locaux
est-ce qu'on peut dépasser cette colère
pour aller vers cet esprit du maire
claude raynal ci voulait bien commencer
cette l'esprit de cette conclusion non
mais je n'entends rien qui serait
hostile à cet esprit mais l'esprit du
maire c'est aussi l'esprit de la de la
discussion
c'est à dire de la confrontation est
évidemment ces deux c'est de la
confrontation connaît la lumière d'une
certaine façon c'est certainement pas
d'un consensus
a priori il n'y a pas de jamais de
consensus a priori moins sûr sur
l'histoire des ath un genre diamant
simplement pour conclure sur ce sujet je
comprends là-dessus andré laignel mais
autant il ya des sujets sur lesquels je
crois le montant par exemple de la
baisse qui nous et je crois qu'il ya un
débat qui va s'ouvrir
autant sur la th il s'agit d'une
promesse électorale je crois que bon
voilà le système est enclenché ce qui
est important c'est qu'à la sortie
évidemment dès les conditions des
manières de le faire et cédera qui
seront en débat et tout va être dans les
détails nous le savons tous mais au-delà
de ça la question qui est fondamentale
derrière c'est qu'on va vers la
suppression pure et simple de la th
voilà ça c'est 7 heures quasiment été
dit par le président de la république
et s'il ne l'avait pas dit on le loue à
assumer ma dont 10 ou insu mais selon
vous non mais si je crois que je crois
que c'est clair on peut pas maintenir 20
% de gens qui payent la taxe est une
taxe c'est impossible
natural à une première qpc une première
question constitutionnelle ça va tomber
mais nettement non d'ailleurs le
gouvernement s'y prépare il est déjà
dans l'idée effectivement de remettre
sur la table les sujets donc c'est ça le
débat
donc qu'est une année où on démarre
puisque c'est un engagement comme on dit
apolitique pris devant les citoyens moi
je crois que ça ne bougera pas mais par
contre que l'on profite cette année pour
tout de suite enclenchée sur
effectivement une réforme complète des
recettes et des finances des
collectivités locales et territoriales
il le faut absolument il faut pas perdre
votre temps
et il faut savoir ensuite comment
gardera le lien avec le citoyen habitant
notre commune
enfin que surtout ça on est une vision
plus globale que ce soit en table comme
ça on le regrette sans doute mais c'est
fait mais par contre que on entame tout
de suite le débat sur la suite est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment aussi cold
par ce dialogue on peut diminuer la
fracture territoriale à l'extérieur
ministre
cette différence entre les métropoles
les autres territoires vous le sentez
vous cette ce cap que je le sente ou pas
il ya des études sociologiques qui le
disent donc j'ai comment dire un certain
respect pour un certain nombre
d'universitaires qui ont produit des
éléments qui sont de nature à minima à
nous faire réfléchir
voilà que la question financière ne soit
pas la totalité de la question c'est
aussi notre certitude c'est à dire que
c'est pas une question purement de
finances locales ça dépasse bien
largement cette question là mais cette
facture oui elle existe
oui elle se ressent oui elle est
traduite également dans les résultats et
draw et ça personne ne peut se dispenser
d'une réflexion sur ce thème
jean claude boulard on peut s'opposer à
la réforme elle va avoir lieu parce que
j'ai dit et 20 brin lieu moi j'ai dit il
faut qu'on n'essaye que on obtient le
maximum de garanties
je n'ai pas donné mon point de vue sont
arrivant on passe notre temps à les
débats troisième jeu conscient que
aujourd'hui par exemple aura lieu il
vaut mieux qu'on se mobilise pour éviter
j'ai rappelé principe dégrèvement
maintien de ben ward et au guichet
fiscal
voilà vous pensez peut-être que vous
allez réussir avait reculé sur la taxe
d'habitation
allez-y on verra bien moi je propose que
on essaye de 2 km par contre l'idée de
s'embarquer sur le verbe locative de
l'habitation
je rappelle c'est nous qui avons bloqué
depuis 30 ans pousse et pourquoi pas ce
que c'est
c'est un impôt de répartition est ce que
vous allez j'ai un endroit où le
réparties sur d'autres notamment sur le
foncier bâti des petits propriétaires
j'ai combattu cette réforme du temps de
furkan je ne regrette pas de l'avoir
convaincu et je vous déconseille
fortement de vous embarquer dans cette
dans un roman à la aussi relisez nos
textes et les raisons pour lesquelles on
a bloqué site à lui sinon tu entends des
élus oublier ce qu'ils ont fait depuis
trente ans en matière de déblocage de 3
troisième élément jeta doublé l'année
dernière on supprime vt
j'entends bien que on explique du
gouvernement refuse le tout début
souvenons-nous crise qu elle est arrivée
sur le vt dans le cas de la majorité
précédente et il ya aujourd'hui il ya
une affaire si elle n'a pas été évoqué
moi je pensais qu'on les veut quand même
chez ses parents qui sont y ait une
perspective d exonération de la cfe ou
là il faut y intégrer dans notre idée
plutôt loi finances sur les
collectivités locales pour qu'on évite
chaque année de se prendre dans le
secteur sectorielle des allégements des
exonérations c'est simplement moi je me
souviens ce qu'on a eue sur le vt
j'aimerais qu'on me rappelle un peu tu
entends aussi c'est cette idée consiste
à critiquer en permanence
ceux qui gouvernent en oubliant ce qu'on
a fait c'est ce qui nous fait perdre du
crédit en terme d'opinion celui qui le
reprend ils ont fait ça ils passent leur
temps à critiquer ce qui arrive je vous
jure que si on veut retrouver un peu de
crédit au peut-être qu'on oublie de
moins ce qu'on a fait ce qu'on n'a pas
critiqué ce qu'on aurait dû créée voilà
les éléments
je vais terminer sur le sujet je trouve
que un gouvernement qui nous propose ici
que nenni de fonctionnement c'est plutôt
c'est plutôt bien
car calculée oit dans la fia des rythmes
scolaires
c'est lui qui me voit chez c'est moi
c'est nous qui payons attendez on arrête
ces systèmes monsieur peillon faisait
payer
moi j'ai combattu cette affaire là j'ai
calculé les économique ça représentait
ce n'est pas négligeable en 2018 donc
j'ai des possibilités d'allègement de
dépenses sans réduction de coûts
d'intervention faut qu'on prenne à bras
le corps les possibilités qui sont
offertes d'un certain nombre de baisses
effectivement de fonctionnement andré
cervera
désolé mon cher jean claude mais les
enfants ne sont pas un agrégat comptable
pour moi je ne considère pas que passer
éventuellement à 4 jours soit un progrès
je pense au contraire que c'est une
grave régression donc vraiment considéré
que c'est une source d'économies quand
elle est faite sur le dos des enfants en
toquant tels que je constate les études
scientifiques qui ont été menées sur les
rythmes de l'enfant
c'est un argument que je ne saurais
recevoir ni acceptés
sur le fond à nouveau on nous parle taxe
d'habitation nous dit c'est un
engagement de campagne
alors j'espère qu'ils médias de par le
président va revenir à 10 milliards
parce que l'engagement de campagne du
président c'est à 10 milliards patrese
ce qui ne veut pas dire que je serais
d'accord avec 10 mais au moins on est
que si ray à partir d'une base déjà plus
modérée donc arrêtons de nous opposer
les engagements de campagne
quand set à sens unique tu demande de la
cohérence
amicalement je t'en demande aussi pour
le reste nous sommes prêts à tout
débattre mais à condition qu'on nous
mette pas devant le fait accompli
quand on nous dit vous venez débattre
mais ces 13 milliards et ça c'est pas
discutable non et moi je considère pas
même sur la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation que tant que le parlement
ne s'est pas exprimée est temps que le
conseil constitutionnel n'a pas à l'idée
que la bataille soit perdue tant que ça
n'est pas promulguée moi je continuerai
à me battre pour que la taxe
d'habitation ne soit pas dans les
conditions actuelles supprimer d'un
trait de plume qui figera les inégalités
on nous dit c'est totalement
inégalitaire mais ce qu'on nous propose
c'est de rembourser par dégrèvement aux
collectivités territoriales sur la base
d extraordinaire inégalités qui
aujourd'hui sont prétextes à la
suppression gelé des inégalités ça ne me
paraît pas un progrès dans la justice
donc non ça n'est pas acceptable thème
reyel vous battre ça passe par quels
moyens
d'abord j'espère que on aura le débat
qu'on pourra convaincre beaucoup de
parlementaires
la naïveté n'est pas forcément ma
qualité première mais en tout cas faut
faire la démarche
et puis je pense qu'il sera nécessaire
sur la taxe d'habitation de saisir le
conseil constitutionnel
parce que je considère qu'il y ait
atteinte forte à la libre administration
à la liberté fiscale à l'égalité entre
contribuables et l égalité entre
collectivités territoriales et là on
mènera ce combat
et puis après écoutez il se peut qu'on
les perde mais en tout cas nous n'aurons
aucun regret d'avoir défendu jusqu'au
bout ce que nous
juste pour nos collectivités
territoriales et après on discutera
alors effectivement du détail mais
d'abord on est sur les principes avant
de se noyer dans les détails qu'on ne
tombe bien donc il ya eu la taxe
d'habitation on a beaucoup parlé aussi
de ce qui a agité pendant cet été
les contrats aidés le ministre en a
touché un mot tout à l'heure c'est aussi
quelque chose de très important peut
être une goutte d'eau qui a fait un
petit peu déborder le vase de la colère
andré laignel oui bien sûr mais enfin je
quand on dit il engage des économies de
fonctionnement mais il engage aussi
d'extraordinaires dépenses de
fonctionnement
j'ai entendu le premier ministre tout à
leur dire il n'est pas normal que soit
l'état qui paie pour des contrats aidés
qui peuvent servir sur des emplois
pérennes
ça veut dire qu'ils renvoient aux
collectivités territoriales le coût des
emplois aidés qu'il cessera de financer
et dans le même temps bien entendu on
nous expliquera que les collectivités
territoriales sont dispendieuses
qu'elles dépensent tout et surtout en
matière de personnel je veux dire on est
dans une contradiction fondamentale
ça ne tient pas ça ne tient pas je peux
ajouter à cela je veux dire je vais
prendre le précédent débat était sur le
logement social
si on touche au logement social tel
qu'aujourd'hui on nous l'indiquent
c'est à dire que pour compenser les
baisses d'apl on va supprimer des
crédits pour les bailleurs sociaux mais
vers qui les bailleurs sociaux vont se
tourner à votre avis vers les
collectivités territoriales on va nous
demander de faire encore plus de réseau
à l'intérieur des lotissements de faire
que ça soit quasiment systématiquement
des terrains gratuits s'y soient mis à
disposition des bailleurs sociaux
il y aura une répercussion d'érable et
bien au delà des pseudos économies qui
étaient évoquées il y à quelques
instants donc méfions nous parce que
derrière une apparente stabilité
il y a d'ores et déjà d'engager des
ricochets qui risque de toucher
brutalement chacune de nos collectivités
territoriales carole delga en quelques
mots pour conclure cette table ronde
avant évidemment la prise de parole de
françois baroin et sur les coûts d'accès
il vous plaît je pense que là dans le
cadre de ces débats nous avons
pu démontrer que tout le monde souhaite
travailler en partenariat avec le
gouvernement mais nous voulons être dans
une démarche qui est constructive mais
où il y a un respect dans les deux sens
bon je pense qu'en effet et je partage
ce que dit jean claude boulard c'est
qu'on ne peut pas être dans des
critiques systématiques l'état de la
france
également dans l'état du monde actuel
demande à avoir une responsabilité une
cohésion mais être responsable
travailler en partenariat je n'ai pas
être dans la béatitude c'est ne pas être
subjugué clairement quand on nous
indique que dans la campagne c'est moins
de 10 milliards pour les collectivités
locales
certains d'entre nous n'étaient pas
d'accord dans le cadre de cette campagne
le soir du premier tour nous avons été
tous en responsabilité pour la
présidentielle parce que nous savions
que c'était l'enjeu de la france de
notre république qui était là après le
coup d'un seul coup c'est il ya 30 %
d'augmentation en 72 heures je trouve
que ce n'est pas respectueux qu'il y ait
moins de 300 millions et qu'on ose dire
que c'est parce que les crédits
n'avaient pas été engagée vous
connaissez en effet la vie politique
depuis plus longtemps que moi monsieur
goulard mais vous savez très bien qu'une
année d'élection présidentielle
les préfets ne sollicite les projets
communaux ou intercommunaux qu'à l'issue
des élections législatives
c'est à dire les maires les présidents
d'intercommunalités ont été sollicités
fin juin alors bien entendu que la part
du s'il n'était pas engagé donc nous
devons être dans cet aspect partenariale
mais les collectivités locales au 21ème
siècle sont un pilier de notre
république est également de la
croissance de notre pays et nous devons
prendre en compte ce fait là nous devons
avoir une france encore plus
décentralisatrice et l'état doit
s'appuyer sur les collectivités locales
et ce partenariat il n'est possible que
s'il ya de la clarté et que s'il ya du
respect et c'est ainsi que nous pourrons
le bâtir moi je pense que le xxième
siècle la république des territoires
c'est à travers la reconnaissance
spécificité territoriale c'est un
travail à travers un plus de pouvoirs
pour nos territoires qu'on construit la
république une et indivisible
nous avons cette maturité politique au
21e siècle et nous devons démontrer la
modernité de la politique non pas en
opposant une ancienne au monde et le
nouveau mais par des actions concrètes
qui reconnaissent une capacité
d'initiative qui reconnaissent la
responsabilité
le sérieux l'engagement des
collectivités locales avec l'état et pas
dans une vision et j'ai moniste ou
centralisatrice merci d'avoir participé
à ce débat je vous demande juste de
rester quelques minutes sur la scène ce
débat sera évidemment diffusé sur
l'antenne de public sénat
je vais appeler jean luc moudenc et le
président de l'aim et françois baroin
bien venir me rejoindre ici pour prendre
la parole dans sa paroisse si vous
voulez bien vous exprimer je vous aide
le micro
de la vision
françois baroin vous avez entendu ce
qu'a dit le premier ministre bien
évidemment jean luc moudenc vous demande
de vous avoir à mes côtés pour résumer
un petit peu tout ce qui a été dit ce
matin au nom de la cohérence aux
demandes du débat et vous aviez demandé
un moratoire il ya un peu de temps au
moment du conseil national des
territoires quand vous entendez tout ce
qui a été dit ce matin est ce que tout
cela va dans le bon sens
d'abord je voudrais remercier france
urbaine de son invitation dire à toutes
et à tous que nous sommes très heureux
de travailler main dans la main je pense
que la france a besoin de métropole
forte a besoin de structures
intercommunales puissante a besoin de
territoire qui s'équilibre et de ce
point de vue cette initiative et est
remarquable je dois dire que la table
ronde à laquelle nous avons assisté avec
des gens très compétents
je connaissais peu madame la présidente
delga j'ai beaucoup apprécié à la fois
son engagement sur l'implication et je
me suis reconnue même si chacun le sait
nous ne sommes pas toujours sur les
grandes orientations d'avenir du pays en
phase et nous avons nos engagements mais
c'est aussi la force de nos territoires
de pouvoir laisser au vestiaire nos
engagements militants et de se mettre
autour de la table pour imaginer définir
ensemble ce qui va dans le sens de
l'intérêt général et je dois dire que
j'ai entendu beaucoup de choses qui vont
dans la direction au fond de notre
ressenti l'élection présidentielle est
passé le président emmanuel macron a été
élu il a été élu sur la base d'un
programme il a été dit dans les
circonstances que nous savons et nous
n'avons aucun a priori sous aucune forme
que ce choix nous étions dans une forme
d'impatience plutôt positive et très
intéressé à l'idée selon laquelle par
ses propos pris dans les engagements de
la campagne puis au lendemain de son
installation il avait fait sien quelques
propos quelques cadres général de
méthodes de travail
pourquoi nous étions impatients à l'idée
de cette conférence nationale et
territoires parce que nous avons subi
comme l'ont dit les orateurs dans cette
table ronde trois années d'une
altération en profondeur de la qualité
des liens qui doivent exister entre
l'état et les collectivités
territoriales
chacun le sait au lendemain du départ de
jean-marc ayrault de matignon les
négociations avec bruxelles se sont
engagés est au fond la france paris à
négocier avec bruxelles de choses on va
faire des économies et on va vous dire
on va aller faire on va les faire sur
les collectivités locales et ça va
passer par deux voix
1 un grand chantier sur les grandes
régions de une organisation globale avec
une saignée de 11 milliards aucun
dialogue aucune discussion on est au
pied du mur de nos responsabilités sur
quelque chose que l'on ne maîtrise pas
et avec un calendrier qui a été
intenable
nous avons alerté les uns et les autres
quelle que soit la taille de nos
communes quelles que soient les
structures que nous portons sur le
risque majeur pour l'effondrement de
l'investissement public et donc pour la
croissance du pays et ce qui s'est passé
est arrivé il ya eu une amélioration du
solde
c'est incontestable il ya eu des efforts
indiscutable mais il ya une chute libre
de l'investissement public de 25% en
trois ans 10% d'investissements publics
dans un modèle économique pour notre
pays c'est 0,2 point de croissance
la france à 0,6 à 0,8 point de
croissance en moins par rapport à la
moyenne de la zone euro au cours de
l'année passée
vous les trouvez là pour partie pourquoi
parce que la commande publique que nous
lancions quelle que soit la taille de la
commune ça tient les tpe ça tient les
pme ça tient le bâtiment ça tient
l'artisanat ça tient les travaux publics
ça tient tous ces territoires et donc le
le réflexe des maires des collectivités
territoriales ça a été de mettre le pied
sur le frein de l'investissement et donc
ça a eu des conséquences économiques
donc cette période passée qui a obtenu
un mouvement puisque françois hollande
président de la république à l'époque
était venu pour amputer de moitié
l'effort qu'ils nous avaient demandé
parce qu'il avait bien mesurer le risque
dramatique qui était en train de se
dérouler sous ses yeux dans nos
territoires il ya eu quand même cette
mobilisation et la mobilisation a eu son
effet maintenant la conférence nationale
les territoires c'était une idée que
nous voulions et nous avons été heureux
qu'elles se tiennent et nous étions
heureux de la préparation je le dis
franchement la phrase que je vais
formuler n'est pas de la mienne elle est
d'un élu qui a parlé d'un été meurtrier
pourquoi parce que comme l'a dit la
présidente belga emmanuel macron s'est
engagé sur 10 milliards ce qui est trop
donc on n'a pas la définition globale
mais il annonce le jour même de
l'ouverture de la conférence nationale
des territoires qu'on passe de dix à
treize c'est pas rien c'est même
considérable c'est 30% en plus avec
l'impact que nous savons sur
l'investissement le lendemain de la
fermeture de la conférence nationale et
territoires où nous avons salué
positivement cette initiative
on apprend en effet le surge elle
l'étagé était ministre du budget le
surge elle il arrive toujours à cette
période sauf que précisément
sur gel des 300 millions il a touché sur
l'adultère et il s'est additionné avec
la suppression de la réserve
parlementaire dont dans l'inconscient
collectif on considère que les
parlementaires une enveloppe et qui l'a
fil à leurs copains pour avoir du
prosélytisme électorale alors que c'est
une ligne budgétaire qui votait dans la
loi de finances pour accompagner les
investissements pour les communes qui
n'en n'ont plus donc l'addition des deux
a créé une deuxième lame de rasoir au
moment où tout le monde était déjà bien
rasé et est présentable pour un été qui
doit être apaisée et à la sortie de
l'été on se retrouve avec l'annoncent
sur la question des emplois aidés le
débat n'est pas pour ou contre les
emplois aidés personne de sérieux de
responsables d'expérimenter sur un
territoire en période de chômage de
masse ne peut contester l'utilité des
emplois aidés qui sont l'ultime levier
d'insertion pour des personnes qui ont
ouvert toutes les portes et qui se
laisse ont vu fermer au nez donc ce
n'est pas le débat le débat c'est la
méthode douce widow tout à l'heure non
mais nous sortons nous sortons d'un
d'une période où l'état le gouvernement
précédent et singulièrement le président
de la république françois hollande est
il
il me semble qu'il ya quand même des
gens qui sont actuellement
responsabilité qui ont participé à cette
politique publique précédente a été loué
en manquait le plus inciter les communes
à faire des emplois aidés justement à
cause de la fameuse courbe du chômage
donc ai jamais eu autant de blog
financier a jamais autant de préfets qui
ont appelé les élus pour leur dire
prenez en prenez-en prenez-en et du jour
au lendemain on ne dit pas vous allez pu
en prendre et si vous voulez les prendre
vous les prenez plein pot et de l'autre
on dit vous allez augmenter votre coût
de fonctionnement et donc c'est
scandaleux et dont vous allez faire des
économies voilà comme l'a dit andré
laignel très justement comme souvent
d'ailleurs est très courageusement comme
toujours d'ailleurs
il a il a mis le doigt sur la réalité de
la schizophrénie donc au fond nous avons
un gros regret à la sortie de cet été ne
sera pas dans une logique de défiance ou
de méfiance nous sommes dans une logique
de décrire ensemble ce pacte de
confiance mais impact juridiquement ces
deux partenaires à égal niveau qui
écrivent ensemble le cadre général du
contrat il ya des draft il ya des textes
qui sont martyrs et puis à la fin il ya
une conclusion est donc là nous sommes
au début d'un processus d'une reconquête
d'une volonté de dialogue
il ya beaucoup de bonnes volontés
personne de sérieux en france imagine
trouver un maire qui ne souhaite pas
apporter sa contribution à
l'assainissement des finances publiques
pour le pays a le mieux
mais personne ne peut non plus remettre
en cause notre constitution la libre à
nice
sur des collectivités territoriales et
le cadre général sur lesquels il ya deux
ou trois sujets en effet les dotations
les emplois et intérêts ils ont trouvé
des solutions pour préparer la rentrée
scolaire faut quand même qu'on écrive la
suite et enfin troisième élément la
question de la taxe d'habitation
beaucoup a été dit je n'ai rien passe
aussi où je souhaitais simplement
peut-être pour revenir un peu sens
créatif de prémices il n'y aura pas de
baisse en 2018 du concours financiers
aux territoires
est ce que vous estimez que c'est un
premier pas un premier pas de dialogue
après ce que vous avez appelé cet été
meurtrier je pense que le discours ce
matin du premier ministre qui sera
probablement confirmé par le ministre d
des comptes publics à intégrer aussi
notre mobilisation collective
il ya une quinzaine de jours sur tous
ces sujets là proches et déjà plus
respectueuse je le dis aussi nous ne
voulons plus entendre les discours sur
il ya trop d'élus où on et clientéliste
les discours sur ya trop d'élus s'est
posé la question de savoir s'il ya trop
de bénévoles s'il ya trop de bénévoles
dans les associations est ce qu'il ya
trop de bénévoles pour aider les
personnes âgées à ce qu elle trop de
bénévoles dans les crèches pour rendre
des services s qui a trompé les vols
dans le milieu sportif
c'est la même chose et nous ne voulons
plus non plus entendre les discours sur
les emplois aidés c'est pour faire du
clientélisme pour ensuite avoir d argent
électoraux pour renouveler son mandat
ça on n'en veut plus donc la proche elle
est me semble-t-il plus positive elle
intègre nos messages de ce début d'année
elle fixe une direction sur lequel on va
avoir des débats j'ai assez d'accord que
il semble assez logique le nouveau
pouvoir légitime est incontestablement
légitime s'appuie sur les engagements
pris devant les français pour les mettre
en application
donc le gouvernement souhaite mettre un
terme sur la question de la taxe
d'habitation
je pense qu'il aura quand même lever la
contradiction sais comment c'est injuste
pour 80% et donc entrepris mais que ça
reste injuste mais on maintient pour les
20% restants j'ajoute que c'est une
grosse concentration sur les 20%
restants deuxième élément le
gouvernement a bien compris le risque
constitutionnel donc il va sur le chemin
du dégrèvement sauf que c'est plein pot
financièrement pour l'état puisque ces
10 milliards et si vous ne faites pas de
dégrèvement vous avez un autre risque
constitutionnel qui est de ne pas
respecter la référence des 70% des
recettes propres de la garantie confère
aux collectivités territoriales donc de
toute façon il ya un chemin constituent
lionel est assez étroit sur cette
problématique des taxes d'habitation
mais nous attendons le débat il se
trouve que le congrès des maires de
france qui sera le centième de l'édition
se tiendra au cours du débat de la loi
de finances je pense qu'il serait utile
que nous formulions nous mêmes des
propositions des contre-propositions
d'une idée d'une fiscalité locale peut
être en faisant du benchmarking
regardez un peu ce qui se passe ailleurs
y compris dans des états de nature
fédérale sont que nous nous allions
naturellement sur ce terrain pour
imaginer conserver quelque chose qui est
essentiel du lien entre la personne qui
vit dans un territoire qui paye une
contribution et qui bénéficient des
services publics
et ça il faut l'imaginer le travail en
sang j'ai deux questions françois barois
aux délégués de parler de saisir le
conseil constitutionnel
c'est quelque chose que vous présidez
mais vous êtes prêt à faire je les ai
déjà fait comme président de la mef
mandaté par les instances transpartisane
de notre structure je rappelle que il ya
tout le monde à l'intérieur et je les
fais par la voie juridique qu'on appelle
la petite porte il ya deux ans sur cette
problématique
l'article qui précise la libre
administration des collectivités
territoriales a été au fond enrichi
entre guillemets parce que ça c'est très
subjectif aussi par un codicille qui
crée la stabilité de la jurisprudence
constitutionnelle sur ce sujet c'est la
libre administration dans les conditions
fixées par la loi
nous avons alerté et nous savons que le
conseil constitutionnel est chaque année
un peu plus vigilant sur le
désengagement de l'état dans la garantie
des recettes propres
il est incontestable que sur ces sujets
nous allons travailler la voie la plus
sûre pour la saisine du conseil
constitutionnel s'est trouvé les
parlementaires relais qui saisiront eux
mêmes je ne doute pas que plusieurs
groupes le formuleront il le formule
rond sur la taxe d'habitation peut-être
et sur la sphère des dotations puisqu'il
y à une annonce de stabilité pour 2018
et il y annonce d'une contractualisation
avec les 220 229 249 qu'on ne sait pas
encore où les 320 ou 329 349 grandes
collectivités territoriales là aussi il
faudra regarder le chemin juridiquement
stable qui garantissent l'équité des
territoires sur le plan fiscal donc ce
sont des trucs à réfléchir dans les
prochaines semaines en tout cas on va
regarder le débat on crie pas avant
d'avoir mal
on a eu mal on a crié allez pour patty
entendu le premier ministre je pense
dans son discours dans cette tonalité et
dans les mesures qui sont formulées qui
seront présentés au cfl la semaine
prochaine et aux parlementaires des
commissions des finances à l'assemblée
au sénat
le mercredi de la présentation en
conseil des ministres cette loi de
finances fixera un cadre
et puis on va discuter nous allons nous
appuyer sur les parlementaires l'autre
élément nouveau
aussi de cette nouvelle législature
c'est que pour la première fois vous
n'aurez plus des gens en bi
responsabilités vous aurez choix des
parlementaires choix des élus locaux
mais vous n'aurez plus des gens qui
incarneront la défense de l'eau
territoire devant la représentation
nationale
il va falloir là aussi imaginer créer
organiser des structures surrénales fait
ça évidemment très bien au sénat la
structure de la délégation des
collectivités territoriales n'existe pas
à l'assemblée nationale nous avons
formulées au nom de la mf la demande
d'une constitution immédiate statutaire
d'une délégation institutionnalisée aux
collectivités territoriales pour qu'on
ait un interlocuteur permanent sur tous
ces sujets qui conditionne pas l'avenir
des maires par l'avenir des conseillers
départementaux pas l'avenir des régions
l'avenir des gens c'est le coin de la
rue qui se décide lorsqu'il ya ces
grands enjeux financiers qui sont
discutées à l'assemblée au sénat
pour information gérald darmanin va pas
tarder à arriver raid est encore au
rendez-vous et que premier ministre mais
il ne va pas tarder à arriver ce qui
nous laisse encore un petit peu de temps
justement vous parliez tout à l'heure de
propositions que vous pourriez formulé
ensemble c'est quelque chose d'important
parce qu'on est dans une séquence de
dialogue besoin de discussion et de
dialogue ce quelle forme pourrait
prendre ces propositions est ce que vous
êtes amené à les formuler
au moment où il y aura le congrès des
maires de france est-ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire un petit peu plus si vous
le savez déjà
nous avons rassemblé toutes les
associations de ce qu'on appelle le bloc
locales et nous avons commencé à définir
une méthode de travail fixé des
objectifs et l'inscrire dans un
calendrier sur cette question de la taxe
d'habitation
nous pensons que le cfl est le mieux
armé pour formuler des propositions et
nous allons essayer de les mettre dans
le débat avant le congrès des maires de
france qui se tiendra dans la troisième
semaine de novembre donc entre début
octobre début de la session après la
présentation de la loi de finances et la
montée en puissance nous formulerons des
propositions concrètes sans avoir à vous
restez avec nous bien évidemment jean
luc moudenc 1 pouvait peut-être
envisager une petite conclusion sur tout
ce qui a été dit station matinée de
débats très importante
on a parlé du logement on a parlé bien
évidemment des finances pendant pendant
un long moment est le vrai ministre est
venu s'exprimer ce que vous pouvez nous
en dire un peu plus sur sa barre heureux
vous donne une micro ce qui ressort de
débat c'est d'abord l'extrême
sensibilité des élus locaux que nous
sommes nous sommes depuis des années
ballotté dans des changements qu'on n'a
pas toujours choisi avec des sujets
importants qui impactent directement
notre action est ce que je retiens aussi
c'est que arrivé à mi mandat le désir de
stabilité et qui est plutôt le nôtre est
encore plus fort le discours du premier
ministre c'est ce qu'a dit françois
baroin à l'instant a été plutôt
rassurant quant aux orientations sur les
sujets qui nous ont beaucoup préoccupés
à savoir la taxe d'habitation et les
fameux 13 milliards pour autant et le
débat qui vient d'avoir lieu l'a dit et
bien dit le diable est dans les détails
et donc les orientations orale que ce
soit à travers le discours du premier
ministre aujourd'hui les discours des
ministres qui vont se succéder les
groupes de travail qui c'est vrai se
sont déroulés dans une ambiance plutôt
positive entre les associations d'élus
et les représentants de l'exécutif
depuis trois semaines
tout ça va dans le bon sens mais on a
bien compris que nous avions la foi du
charbonnier et qu'en la matière
voulons voir les choses dit de venir
écrite est gravé dans le marbre et ce
n'est qu'à ce moment là que nous serons
pleinement rassuré ça veut pas dire qu'à
partir de ce moment-là nous fermerons
les yeux et nous baisserons les bras car
nous savons bien que 1 plf c'est un plf
et qu'il y à l'année d'après et qui a
les années d'après donc je crois que
chacun a compris que nous étions
extrêmement vigilant sur les questions
du logement
bien évidemment nous sommes aux première
loges puisque souvent nos concitoyens
quand ils sont à la recherche du
logement social
ils viennent d'abord vers leur mère vers
leurs élus locaux et c'est vrai que nous
allons être très attentifs aux annonces
de ce jour pour voir comment un discours
qui personnellement m'a parer à ce stade
contradictoires peut s'équilibrer
contradictoires d'un côté on dit il faut
que les loyers baissent qui peut être
contre la baisse des loyers pour les
français les plus en difficulté qui sont
dans le logement social
pas grand monde mais en même temps on
dit il faut le dire il faut développer
le logement social nous devons créer du
logement social et nous adhérons tout à
fait à cette vision des choses
simplement pour développer le logement
social
il faut des moyens et notamment des
moyens financiers comment demander aux
bailleurs de baisser leurs ressources au
profit de leurs locataires et en même
temps de doper leurs investissements
pour créer davantage de logement social
il ya là un risque de contradiction et
donc nous allons être très attentifs
aujourd'hui pour savoir comment le
gouvernement résout la contradiction et
assurent l'équilibré entre les deux
ensuite je crois que ça a été dit par
les collègues qui ce matin se sont
exprimés parce qu'ils suivent davantage
les questions de logement social outils
de france urbaine
nous nous sommes prêts
à exercer des responsabilités renforcées
en matière d' aides à la pierre nous
pensons que la méthode décentralisatrice
là aussi est la bonne méthode
mais là aussi attention
nous serons attentifs aux conditions
dans lesquelles tout ça se fera pour une
raison très simple c'est qu'en matière
des de la pierre il y à ce que fait
l'état il ya ce qui est décentralisé
mais il y a déjà beaucoup de financement
que nous apportons par nous mêmes et qui
pèse beaucoup
et donc là aussi soyons extrêmement
vigilants sur les modalités c'est dans
les modalités qu'en réalité se joue soit
la confirmation d'une volonté politique
soit son délitement jean luc moudenc on
peut éventuellement parler un petit peu
de en détail des annonces qui ont été
faites par le premier ministre en tout
cas des ébauches de l'ours avant le
projet de loi devant le projet de loi de
finances bien évidemment il n'a parlé de
bon sens budgétaire il a expliqué
également qu'il y avait le pari de la
confiance ce pari de la confiance
on sent bien qu après la colère des élus
et ce bar voisin témoin principal
il ya un problème entre vous les
territoires ce que représentait les
territoires et le gouvernement comment
aujourd'hui on dépasse cette colère
d'abord je crois que françois l'a bien
résumé on a vécu deux saisons la saison
sous le quinquennat précédent où la
brutalité des décisions unilatérales
s'est abattue sur nous avec une baisse
drastique de moyens que nous n'avions
jamais connu
et puis à la saison 2 qui est le temps
de la nouvelle présidence qui commence
avec de bonnes intentions affichées mais
des faits qui sont venus contrarier et
contredire les bonnes intentions
donc nous abordons l'automne est donc là
la temporalité de fabrication la loi de
finances avec des sentiments un peu
partagé on peut tout de même
nous comprendre et donc c'est vrai nous
sommes devenus extrêmement vigilant
extrêmement sensible et ce n'est que par
je dirais des faits corroborés cohérents
par une conformité des actes par rapport
au discours que la confiance que moi je
souhaite parce que nous les maires les
prisons d'intercommunalité on n'aspire
qu'à une chose c'est travailler
normalement et dans de bonnes conditions
avec le gouvernement donc ce n'est qu'à
cette condition là que la confiance sera
au rendez vous des faits des actes merci
joli coup d'oeil
pour information la salle vous applaudir
bien évidemment jarre dahmane a été
reçue retenu un petit peu à matignon il
viendra en début d'après midi pour
parler vous exprimer ici par rapport à
exactement tout ce qui a été dit ce
matin par le premier ministre est
peut-être éventuellement faire quelques
annonces
nous avons ce matin un premier sera fait
un discours me semble-t-il très
important pour l'intégralité des élus et
particulièrement ému trans'urbaines je
voudrais d'abord entre premier remercier
jean luc moudenc qui est un petit peu
aussi mon président et c'est un peu mon
association c'est quand vous le savez
voilà encore quelques jours j'étais élu
d'une grande ville et qui salue le
travail très important de jean luc et de
toutes ses équipes sur la fiscalité la
fiscalité particulièrement écologique
l'idée est une idée assez simple que
celle du président a répliqué du premier
ministre sous le couvert du ministre
d'état nicolas hulot s'était pas une
fiscalité qui est là pour embêter cette
fiscalité qui est là pour transformer et
parmi les transformations il faut éviter
à la fois qu'elle touche le monde
économique et à ce titre l'augmentation
du prix du diesel ne touchera pas la
plus grande partie de ceux qui par leur
fruit d'un travail par les transporteurs
les taxis les agriculteurs dont vous
reconnaîtront pas cette augmentation
même temps qui doit lutter très
fortement contre un moyen de locomotion
qui nous a malheureusement poser un
sérieux problème notamment un très
grande commune je parle des très grandes
métropoles et sur des pics de pollution
qui sont nées des particules fines et
l'idée c'est vraiment que l'argent qui
vient de cette fiscalité écologique dont
j'imagine que sébastien vous a parlé
permettra de financer les primes à la
casse
très importante les chèques énergie que
nous allons généraliser et
l'accompagnement des élus locaux dans
transformation leur territoire et
particulièrement dans la transformation
écologique de leur territoire sherman en
2010 ce matin dans son discours à nous a
dit nous a annoncé ici qu'il n'y aurait
pas de baisse des dotations pour 2018 il
a parlé d'une augmentation globale de
plus de 384 millions d'euros pouvez vous
préciser la démarche
alors c'est une démarche nouvelle
puisque 2002 puis 2011 les dotations
baissé et parfois elles baissé à un
rythme extrêmement important chaque élu
pourrez le constater quand on parle de
notation parle bien sûr de la dgf
interne la dgf de la dsu et et la dsr
mais aussi de toutes les dotations donc
ce qu'a précisé le premier ministre ce
matin c'est que l'intégralité des
transferts aux collectivités locales qui
sont en général sous l'égide du
ministère de l'intérieur du midi d'état
jarkko l'ont effectivement va augmenter
et or de peu mais va augmenter puisque
400 millions c'est une somme importante
bien sûr pour les français mais assez
modeste il faut bien l'avouer sur la
masse globale de notation mais c'est la
première fois que nous reprenons depuis
une ascension des crédits pour les
collectivités locales et l'intérieur de
cette enveloppe
il ya plusieurs enveloppes sans trop les
détailler ici la detr sera maintenu
alors que l'année dernière le milliard
de deux terres qui étaient inscrits au
budget était tout à fait exceptionnel et
ça avait été pré cité comme mesures qui
n'étaient pas pérenne la d6 sera
évidemment maintenus au même niveau tout
ce qui concerne la politique de la ville
et je mets à part
l'anru qui va connaître un doublement
des crédits comme l'a évoqué le
président de la république de 5 à 10
milliards ce sera bien de voir voir
augmenter et je crois que la stratégie
logement a été va continuer de présenter
et notamment l'augmentation la
multiplication par deux des crédits pour
la politique de rénovation urbaine
exactement et je pense qu'il aura
l'occasion de préciser la grande
ambition qu'ils portent notamment sur le
logement à l'est et les politiques du
logement et puis à l'intérieur les
dotations la dgf va elle que d'être une
augmentation de plus de 100 millions et
ensuite viendra aux parlementaires bien
sûr le choix de redistribuer s'ils le
souhaitent dans une péréquation que
chacun ici peut écouter à temps ou
parfois redouté ce sera débat
parlementaire en tout cas si un
changement de péréquation voulu elle ne
sera pas du fait de la baisse des
dotations pour la première fois depuis
2011 mais l'état va donc inscrire
un budget non seulement stabilité mais
en légère hausse alors gérald darmanin
13 milliards d'euros d'économies sont
demandés aux collectivités territoriales
sur cinq ans edouard philippe l'a
annoncé ce matin ses économies prendront
en compte l'évolution naturelle des
dépenses est ce que c'est une main
tendue aux élus locaux après un été
meurtrier pour reprendre l'expression
employée ici même ce matin par françois
baroin alors moi j'entends que à
quelques jours des sénatoriales
l'inflation verbale soit au rendez vous
mais je crois que lorsqu'on supprime 300
millions d'euros sur un budget global
qui bien qu'ils se comptent en milliards
presque l'ensemble des dépenses des
collectivités locales c'est 170
milliards d'euros et lorsqu'on évoque
des mesures autour de 300 millions ce
qui a été meurtrier c'est plutôt les
baisses de notation que nous avons tous
subi en tant qu'élus locaux et sans
concertation
c'est la première fois que le
gouvernement et chacun peut comprendre
pourquoi les uns et les autres
d'ailleurs l'ont fait mais qu' un
gouvernement maintient les dotations
d'abord c'est ta premiers signes et
bourzat mon avis un signe d'amour il ya
des gens qui parlent et puis à des gens
qui font des démonstrations d'amour
peut-être que les démonstrations sont
plus parlantes aujourd'hui que les
annonces la deuxième des choses c'est
qu'effectivement la volonté générale
c'était quand même de rappeler aux élus
et tous les élus le savez la très grande
majorité d'entre eux savent ce que c'est
que de gérer un budget et de gérer
malheureusement un compte ils reprennent
une collectivité ou quand il succède à
quelqu'un d'avoir des projets de
financer les anciens de rembourser une
dette qui parfois est insupportable et
puis de faire face mais mais mais
malheureusement à une demande
particulière de dépenses parce qu'on a
plus d'habitants ou parce que les
dirigent itil très forte notamment en ce
qui concerne la masse salariale est bien
de nous nous avons considéré qu'il ne
fallait pas forcer les élus à faire des
économies mais il fallait partager la
contrainte comme le disent et sans doute
le premier ministre tout à l'heure et
essayer de lutter contre l'endettement
d'une partie des collectivités même
s'ils ont tous d'accord que c'est
d'endettement ne compte que pour moins
de 10% de l'endettement global du pays
mais aussi en évitant les augmentation
tendancielle de dépenses alors on va
vendredi avec le ministre d'état
travaille avec toutes les associations
d'élus nous avons
je crois démontré par notre premier acte
qui consiste à ne pas baisser les
dotations qu'effectivement c'est une
main tendue extrêmement forte qu'on peut
rien faire sur les territoires rien
faire particulièrement sur les grandes
villes et les grands territoires de
france et j'espère qu'on arrivera à voir
le pacte girondins que le président de
la république a présenté dans la
conférence nationale du territoire et
arrêter d'avoir une volonté jacobine qui
était une baisse au pourcentage un peu
partout selon les territoires selon le
passé selon les difficultés selon le
nombre d'habitants c'est au contraire de
ce que nous souhaitons faire en quelque
sorte vous renouer le dialogue après un
été difficile
oui après des années difficiles je pense
que les collègues étaient difficiles le
ministre
moi je pense que c'est surtout les
années précédentes qui étaient
difficiles quand on baisse des dotations
enfin moi j'ai je prenais mon expérience
personnelle je suis depuis que j'ai été
élu maire en 2014
il a fallu que je connaisse entre une
belle dotation entre 5 et 15% de
dotation en moins dans une ville qui
connaît 21 % de taux de chômage
alors même que l'état nous demander de
faire un certain nombre de choses à sa
place sans transférer un certain nombre
de charges qui pourtant sont de ses
compétences premières
je pense par exemple carte d'identité ou
un passeport dont chacun peut constater
la différence entre le coût pour les
collectivités et la dotation de l'état
était différente donc avec le ministre
d'état qui a été un très grand maire de
lyon et qui sait ce que gérer une
collectivité veut dire je crois que vous
avez jacques mézard et gérard collomb et
permettez moi de dire à quelques élus
dont sébastien qui préside un
département les gens qui connaissent la
vie locale et qui connaissent la
difficulté des élus ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il faille démagogues ça veut pas dire
qu'il faut raser gratis qui connaissent
la vie difficile des élus je crois que
vendredi le ministre d'état gérard
collomb aura l'occasion avec nous
d'annoncer quelques bonnes nouvelles
pour rétablir me semble-t-il ce lien de
confiance à vous demander quand même des
efforts aux collectivités locales mais
évidemment mais quels sont les efforts
de l'état que vous allez lancer dans les
prochains jours mais l'état fait des
efforts et j'espère qu'il ne fera plus
que les années précédentes puisque il
est vrai que les collectivités locales
ont participé plus que l'état en
proportion de leurs dépenses publiques
en proportion de leur endettement et ça
c'est quelque chose à corriger
il faut que les collectivités locales
continuent et là je parle devant des
élus souvent urbain
je pense même que les élus qui gèrent
des plus grosses collectivités doivent
aussi prendre conscience qu'ils ont plus
de marge de manoeuvre que les plus
petites communes
notamment les communes rurales ça je
pense que chacun peu plus longtemps mais
il est sûr que c'est à l'état
désormais de faire la plus grosse partie
de l'effort et c'est ce que nous allons
présenter le 27 septembre avec bruno le
maire nous allons présenter un dé
transformation très profonde dans le
pays nous avons annoncé et la presse
s'en est fait l'écho de transformation
extrêmement profonde pour l'année
prochaine la politique du travail la
politique du logement
nous continuerons à le faire le
président de la république a annoncé un
certain nombre de mesures pour revoir
les missions et pour remettre en phase
de ses missions un certain nombre de
moyens et d'efforts il est certain que
si la dépense publique était la seule
solution à la difficulté des français
alors ça va bien longtemps que tout le
monde serait très heureux de notre pays
edouard philippe ce matin est revenu sur
l'une des réformes engagées par le
gouvernement celle de la taxe
d'habitation
elle entrera en vigueur en 2018 est ce
que vous pouvez nous préciser
concrètement le dispositif
alors nous allons effectivement dans
projet de loi de finances 2010 8 non
seulement mettre le principe me mettre
la chronique
donc nous voterons nous proposerons
parlementaires de voter la chronique des
trois ans qui supprimera à terme pour 23
millions de foyers 80% de la taxe
d'habitation
concrètement ce sera un dégrèvement ce
ne sera pas une exonération
donc je crois que chacun ici pour être
assurés sur le fait que l'état va
prendre ses responsabilités y compris
lorsqu'il ya une dynamique municipale
une dynamique urbaine réparer un impôt
qui en plus non seulement est injuste
pour les citoyens entre eux mais on le
sait bien injuste entre collectivités et
je pense que ça c'est un sujet
extrêmement important et qu'il faut
savoir résoudre désormais personne n'a
le courage parce que tout le monde peut
donner deux sont aujourd'hui mais depuis
ce sont des années 70 de réviser les
valeurs locatives
ce qui pose quand même un certain nombre
de problèmes évidemment de la justice
devant l'impôt et nous allons donc des
gréves et chaque année d'année prochaine
30% puis 35 et 35% pour arriver
effectivement à 100 % la taxe
d'habitation pour 80% des français
ce qui est certain et pour être conforme
au discours du président de la
république non seulement c'est une
mesure de pouvoir d'achat qui ne grève
pas la vie des collectivités locales qui
bien sûr auront la possibilité de
continuer à fonctionner et pourquoi pas
d'augmenter ou de baisser les taux s'il
le souhaite
ce qui est certain c'est qu'il faudra se
poser pendant ces trois ans et nous
comptons bien sûr sûr
les élus et notamment lors leur volonté
pour faire quelque chose
évidemment de moderne et de très
pratique nous pouvons réfléchir demain à
l'existence de ce que doit être une
fiscalité locale moderne qui doit être
basée sur autre chose que des valeurs
locatives des années 70 et qui doit
obtenir la conséquence de la suppression
de la taxe professionnelle du fait
métropolitain pour une partie d'entre
eux peut être demain de la
recentralisation ou non du rsa dans les
départements
peut-être la transformation en métropole
dans certains endroits il y a
aujourd'hui déjà des différences entre
l'île de france qui peut lever une taxe
particulière notamment pour la société
du grand paris et notre région
d'autres collectivités qui ne peuvent
pas utiliser un impôt donc une égalité
du territoire à avoir et sans doute
pendant les trois ans qui arrive un
sujet extrêmement important de refonder
la fiscalité locale
le président de la république a évoqué
la conscience nationale des territoires
l'idée d'être très descriptif et a
précipité de faire un nouvel impôt local
qui remplacerait pourquoi pas les 20 %
de gens qui payent encore la taxe
d'habitation et imaginons une autre
l'impôt local qu'à taxe foncière il est
aussi évoqué le point de cg le point
lire pp le point de tva les régions vont
avoir et ça c'est un projet de budget un
point de tva qui va donner 100 millions
de recettes dynamiques chaque année en
plus aux régions donc en plus ils vont
avoir plus de dotations donc la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation
n'est qu'une première étape pour la
refonte totale de la fiscalité locale
une suppression totale de la taxe
d'habitation ça c'est quelque chose qui
est envisageable à moyen terme
alors aujourd'hui ce n'est pas prévu ce
qui est bien prévu c'est effectivement
la suppression pour 81 des français par
paliers deux tiers pour leur redonner du
pouvoir d'achat 600 euros cette année en
moyenne payées par les français ce sera
400 euros l'année prochaine puis 200
puis 0 mais effectivement nous ne
pouvons pas nous interdire d'ouvrir la
question le chantier de la fiscalité
locale et de la rendre plus moderne en
lui comment ses difficultés ses
difficultés de sociologie ces
difficultés de revenu dans ma propre
commune pour parler encore de chez moi
c'est ce que je connais le mieux dans
les années 70 la le quartier qui
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs être quartier aux
rues qui aujourd'hui connaît 60 % de
familles monoparentales
la secrétaire paye parfois 1000 euros de
taxe d'habitation
en revanche l'avocat d'affaires qui
habite dans mon quartier qui dans les
années 70 était un champ
dans une maison assez bourgeoise
payement qu'un secrétaire dans le
quartier en rue peut-être que c'est un
impôt injuste
interrogeant un terme à neuf si vous
voulez bien sur cette taxe d'habitation
ce matin les débats nous ont ramenés
évidemment sur cette question il y avait
des personnalités représentant de
delahaye maire et le président de la mmf
et le vice-président nous ont parlé de
saisir le conseil constitutionnel sur
cette question est ce que c'est quelque
chose qui vous choque pas du tout moi je
pense qu'il est très important que
toutes les voies de droit soit soit
étudié ce qui est certain c'est qu'on a
fait un choix et ce choix c'est à la
fois de garantir aux collectivités
locales leur argent le dégrèvement
j'appelle aujourd'hui que 12 millions de
foyers ne payent déjà pas la taxe
d'habitation puisqu'à dix mille 700
euros par an est ce qui est de quelque
chose parfois d'assez couru dans les
villes populaires vous ne payez pas
votre taxe d'habitation qui a déjà
système d'exonération d'abattement et de
dégrèvement il y à une qpc qui est
possible qu'ils aient rendu par la
république les parlementaires derrière
on le droit de saisir s'ils le
souhaitent
la loi de finances et c'est d'un pas
certain mais conscient du pouvoir
d'achat nos concitoyens que nous
proposons cette mesure qui d'ailleurs
est conforme me semble-t-il des modes
démocratique puisqu'il était confirmée
non seulement la présidentielle mais aux
élections législatives dernière question
gérald darmanin sur un autre sujet
l'ensemble des associations d'élus
locaux se plaignent du caractère trop
normatif de l'état comment alléger le
poids des normes
c'est une question extrêmement
importante parce que les normes à chaque
fois qu'un premier ministre et qu'un
nouveau gouvernement arrivé
malheureusement il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'exceptions il y a en général des
déclarations pour dire on va baisser les
normes et à la fin on s'aperçoit que
c'est pas simple la simplification si je
peux me permettre
on a même connu jeune parlementaire des
articles plus longs d'exception que de
simplification il ya donc un certain
nombre de principes qu'il faut changer
et nous allons les mettre dans la loi et
nous on les met dans le principe de
fonctionnement du pays
c'est de l'objet du texte que présent
applique maintenant être portée qui est
le droit à l'erreur le changement de
règle
l'administration doit démontrer l'erreur
et non pas l'un vers ce ça vaut non
seulement pour particuliers
d'entreprises mais ça vaut aussi pour la
collectivité locale deuxièmement nous
allons faire ce que le présent dans le
public a souhaité aujourd'hui dans le
cadre constitutionnel peut être demain
dans le cas d'une réforme nous verrons
bien
l'expérimentation afin d'adapter la
réglementation
un certain nombre de mesures dans le
monde économique
pour ce qui concerne la précéder
préfecture nos six concerts des
collectivités locales seront proposés la
simplification il faut là encore éviter
d'en parler et essayer de la faire
merci beaucoup merci monsieur ministre
d'être venu cet après midi ministre de
l'action et des comptes publics je vous
laisse regagner la salle
[Musique]